The joe rogan experience.
Remember growing pains my own before Kirk Cameron became one of the most awesome
lovers.
Why is it banana shaped the way it is?
I never told you to explain that shit.
Joe.
I actually was on a plane with Kirk Cameron recently and he was just sitting
there looking so sad and depressed and I,
cause it was one of those things where uh,
I was waiting for somebody else to put like their luggage up so I was just
standing right next to him and he's just sitting there like looking at his
phone,
like looking past his phone,
not even looking what's on the screen and he just sat there and then like some
woman came up to him and he just looked up and went like did those are like
little smile but it was so weird being
to wouldn't,
you can imagine every day the guy is fighting off the gay with every fiber of
his being.
He is just clenching his teeth and finding out if you really want to save Kirk
Cameron,
this is what you do.
If you're a big gay guy,
sit in his lap and pull your cock out and he'll just,
he'll suck on it like a baby to its mother's breasts.
Banana peel on that first security.
That's what he's doing.
He's just fighting off the gay tooth and nail and claw and Fang.
So funny to me how the not people who are most outspoken against homosexuality
gaze.
Look at him.
He's so obviously gay.
You can't get any obviously gayer than Kirk.
Cameron not does anything wrong with being obviously either.
I mean for the guy to be happy,
she just come out of the closet.
All of them just come out.
What do you think about the Tom Cruise?
A Scientology,
Surrey or whatever and that whole thing.
It's amazing.
The Tom Cruise already has a new Ukrainian beauty,
fantastic picture of him and her holding hands are ready in a magazine like a
such an obviously stage picture.
You're like Scientology are bad motherfuckers cause they're still rocking it.
Old School in 2012 all right.
They're putting together storylines,
they're creating like narratives.
They have like a whole fucking publicity.
So like,
like whole area.
A department that like figures out how to handle it when you Tom,
my girlfriend and we need Tom girlfriend know,
right?
It's like an a newsroom.
Like that's it.
They're,
they're the,
the like the News Corp,
but we spotted Caney holds New York step pitches in New York.
Shit,
we need Tom with a hot Russian right.
Right now.
And Tom.
Okay.
You're going to go on Ellen this time and jump on the couch and you're gonna say
you're in love and you're in.
I don't care if you're 15 if you want to fix your career,
jump on that woman's couch.
All things Seaton
the,
the videos of them,
like people trying to go into their welcome to the public kind of festivals and
them coming out and aggressively swarming around people and screaming,
what's your issue?
What's your problem?
What are you hiding?
What are you afraid of?
It's,
that's,
that's scary shit.
They love the company of Bigot too.
That's like a big one.
They call people bigots.
Beg It.
You're a bigot.
Yeah.
Scientology's fascinating organization to me.
And just let the dogs help people though,
man.
No doubt about,
I have a neighbor who was a scientologist who's out in Nice fucking guy,
man.
He's a great guy.
And he,
it helped man.
Hey Dude tells you all the great things that he did for him and how it helped
his business,
helped his life and helped us focus and this and that and fucking believes in
it.
Who are you tell them differently?
Kevin Pereira.
I'm nobody.
Joe Rogan.
Do you think,
um,
how much of a Tom Cruise's life is surrounded by Scientologists?
Is he just like,
you know,
uh,
Scientology
by God [inaudible] he goes,
yeah,
I think,
is he the head guy?
He wears the pig helmet at the meeting.
You know,
like he's the one that's like the deepest in and I think,
I think there's like a group of like probably like six main players and he's
like the one in the head guys,
you know,
it's,
I like that you've just created your own fucking council of dude.
Right?
Seriously.
He's in a meeting,
they're hollowed out volcano.
Ever seen the video?
The staff were full.
He's like one of the most powerful guys ever.
It is,
can you pull up
the video of him in the,
do you know the Scientology video where he is a,
it's a video that wasn't supposed to get,
it was like supposed to play it like a conference or something.
Right.
And it was supposed to be in the,
yeah.
I don't know what you would said Tom Cruise.
Creepy speech.
Scientology,
but whatever it is,
they,
they had it set up.
Excuse me.
They had it set up in this,
um,
like a hole.
There was like a whole auditorium of people that were like watching this tape,
right,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
And like cheering along with it and shed him.
Am I remembering that right?
No,
I think it wasn't any,
it was like an annual meeting,
like a seminar.
Like you sit through that and then they offer you a time share and then you get
to go skiing.
Poor Katie Holmes,
poor Jason.
But didn't she sign up?
Like I've always heard,
I've always heard,
hey,
sign up.
Sign up for it.
Yeah.
And it's like when you get this much money and sure.
Monitor career to come back.
I just wanted to be relevant,
you know,
and guess what man,
that's the only way to do it for a lot of these girls,
you know all these middling girls,
you know,
they're doing pretty good there.
Okay.
And you know,
five years goes by and she's 39 ou pass and that's it.
It's over.
Yeah.
So you've got to make a,
you got to bust a move before your fucking rice runs out of the stock.
It sand out of the thing
San out of the hourglass or the that thing.
The old rice bucket.
Right.
What did I feel like there's a similar measuring devices,
rice and some cultures.
Yeah,
look at them all clapping.
He's got a metal,
he did it.
It's got a metal to metal heat.
One the religion.
I've never been
met a more competent the world or background.
Podium tolerant,
more compassionate being outside of what I've experienced from LRH and I've met
the leaders of leaders.
Okay.
I've met them all.
So I say to you,
sir,
cob,
we are lucky to have you and thank you.
Beautiful.
He's beautiful.
Was an l Ron busted on like a boat in international waters having sex with
underage people.
Yup.
Okay.
Something,
well maybe not.
I just put I said yeah,
what made it so there we go update the Wiki.
Can we just get that and that's not even the man.
Um,
there's
one where he's appearing by tape,
right?
Yeah.
That's the one I originally found but I thought you were talking about that one.
That was beautiful too though.
He's beautiful.
He's just so charismatic.
Sign up for five years with that.
Especially if it helped my career.
If I just had a inkling of,
of the possibility that maybe he would hang out with me.
Right.
Cultures,
that's it.
I think I the music like
that,
once you know these tools and you know that they work,
it's just not good enough and I'm just doing okay traveling the world and
meeting the people that I've met now talking with these leaders get various
fields,
they want help and they are depending on people who know and who can be
effective and do it now and that's us.
That is our responsibility to do that.
It is the time.
Now is the time.
Stop it.
Stop this beautiful,
beautiful.
You better.
You better know it.
And if you don't
go and learn it,
oh that's the option.
If I don't know it,
learn it.
It's not even the end of it.
The end of it is what I wanted to hear.
What he says that if you stop by an accident,
you know you have to do something cause you,
you're assigned to it.
It's an eight minute video.
Oh here I'll try and skip.
Don't,
don't make me get my dick hard freight.
Yeah.
That's too intense for me.
I just loved the beautiful possible music.
I love the,
you know,
I love all of them are religious mission.
Should you choose to accept it and the Nike yourself distresses.
Yeah,
the com conviction.
I love the,
the fake actor intensity involved in it and I know that he's just thinking of I
have one more hour this and I'm going to fuck everyone cause he's got this like
10 dudes just waiting for him.
They're prepping them right?
He's like a horse that knows he's on the end of the trail and he's getting back
to the feed bag there.
She knows there's 12 dudes in the back of warming up,
waxing their beetles that have done everything right
click every day.
When I think about those people out there who are depending on us,
it does make me,
Sheila,
we got more work.
I need more help.
I'll get those spectators.
You're into playing field or out of the arena
in the playing field or out of the arena.
That has been great.
Yeah.
You're either with us who have the answers and we have,
we can provide all the help to
kill ladies and gentleman,
please watch the whole thing because there's so much glory in it.
There's so much awesomeness in it.
It's so ridiculous,
but you know what man?
It's like we,
we value charisma like that so much that a guy like that who can step up and
tell you what Scientology can do to maximize you and that you will be a better
person.
It's not if you become a but you will be a better person.
Thank you very much.
The reason you're not right now is because you haven't joined.
Come on,
dude.
How crazy do you have to be to be wearing a metal to wear a fucking Olympic gold
medal bigger than the Olympic medal?
The date they said,
what's the Olympic medal?
Mega 10% bigger because this is important.
This brings into one giant metal and make it match his eyes.
We make it out of the gold we took from the fillings at Auschwitz and yeah,
that's special evil goal that we have saved up that we'd been a radiating and
saying mean things to for years.
One fucking pile of all the gold that they know was made in and gotten through
the worst circumstances like black beards,
fucking pirate treasure mean.
We know he murdered babies for this goal.
Oh,
this is the gold.
I want mold into that.
What do you do?
What do you,
what are you watching?
The flights?
No,
you're Tom Cruise screensaver cooked in all your photos of the half naked said.
Okay,
stop right there.
Back up a second.
Think about this real quick.
Look at him with Val Kilmer.
Yeah,
I'll think about what he looks like,
which is the fucking same.
He's showing him the house,
put inside them in this photo.
What Val Kilmer looks like.
He's saying,
I'm getting you to the elbow.
I iceman.
Val Kilmer.
Val Kilmer has continued to age whereas Tom Cruise had,
he got to a certain point and then just stopped because he's been eating from a
human liver restaurant and you don't know about it yet.
The Petri dish.
Human Liver restaurant.
Yup.
He goes into the cryo freezer especially picks his organs as in love with
Katie's back in the day.
Meanwhile,
what is he thinking about their cock?
That's what he's thinking about.
Cock is thinking about cost there.
He's like,
oh,
that seasons he's ready for it.
Actually only for cock.
I actually want to say on the record that I don't think he's gay and he doesn't
want like that because in my name is Brian Ryko over in my use,
my main stage names Red van and I disagree with everyone here.
Mr. Cruz and I'm sorry,
what'd you do with it if he doesn't,
even if he doesn't want cock,
I think you should try it.
Yeah.
Cause uh,
it might be his thing.
Brian,
would you do a five,
five year stint with Tom Cruise?
If it meant unlimited wealth and career success?
Five months.
Let's just say five months in my compound.
Oh,
I have to have sex or just hang out with him for thank you have to.
You have to either stuck or be fucked by Tom Cruise.
One of the two has to happen for sure.
I unlimited wealth,
unlimited wealth.
Sure.
And success.
What'd you do now?
Career success.
Five months.
Tom Cruise.
Sex Life.
Absolutely not.
You wouldn't for unlimited.
Well No.
What is unlimited wealth?
Doe just never having to worry about it.
Yeah,
but could you buy like jets and shit?
Certainly.
You can imagine your butthole.
You're letting a guy fuck your butthole was worth that much.
It was like there was a way you can negotiate it.
I'm sure it is.
The some salt out there somewhere now.
People think of it that they're like sucked your Dick just for dinner and like,
really,
I could have gotten unlimited
wealth of,
I just got a better agent.